do you expect them to go for the kill in
this game David judging from the way he
played this first game today it feels
like Magnus is Out For Blood he starts
with the English opening
um yeah we saw yesterday when in the
final game in game three when Magnus
only needed a draw he played very
passively played for the draw he was
significantly worse after the opening so
I think Magnus is uh trying to make
amends for that he's now he's definitely
not chosen a passive opening it's the
king's Indian defense the Magnus
occupying the center with all his Pawns
and uh what will you choose now it's
difficult to just kill the game against
the king's Indian
it's difficult to go straight for a draw
uh where he actually sacked a queen in
the end to get Victory and he's gone for
an older but I say old variation the
same-ish variation
um which is is a very decent line as
well oh wow above perfect but not too
bad yeah
decent rating yeah meanwhile we do see
one of your Pawn pushers Simon and
Magnus immediately blocks up the center
white can't let things open up because
White's lacking in development uh
White's King still several moves away
from castling and uh it's a nice Pawn
chain for white but black I'm expecting
to chip away at that pawn structure
again just first kicking backwards
Bishop
White's Bishop is happy to actually lose
time and uh now Arjun trying to open the
center
or main Life Theory this I mean I I
remember playing this line as white
um some of course a long time ago at
least 20 years ago uh it was one of my
favorite variations but black does does
get a lot of counter play so this is
this is a good choice for margin who
really needs to win has to win one of
the games of black to have any chance so
he's picked the right opening and and
there's many moves that black can try
here to to gain counter play but first
of all he develops his Knight which is
coming towards the center and again this
is all pretty pretty uh known Theory so
far Magnus in his last game eliminated
that night with his Bishop but Arjun
can't do that because he's blocked it so
it's a good point and now the White
Knight gets his ideal Square first of
all you have to stop Black's plan always
look with your opponent's last move is
always try to work out what they're
trying to do and of course he doesn't
stop it because I've said that and
actually Matthew Sadler used to play
This Way black to now push on the queen
side can I just oh yeah David's got it
highlighted sorry go on your right no no
no I was um I'll leave it to you yeah
um so just to backtrack a couple of
moves in this position white after the
black porn push white could not actually
take this pawn it looks like a free uh
Pawn here it's defended by the queen but
black now has a nasty tactic Black's
Knight can jump out the way capture a
pawn hitting the White Queen and when
this Knight is captured the black queen
can sweeping uh with a check also
hitting the white Bishop so for example
here black takes the white bishop and
black has full domination over the dark
squares along this diagonal so this one
was finally threatened so black didn't
have time to commit sure and uh push his
Pawn so we saw uh let's catch up with
the gaming position it's all about this
Pawn break Magnus is castled in the
meantime and uh Black's trying to force
this one through as you mentioned
earlier Simon the white show is a
different plan which is actually to
slide The Rook one square across and the
whole idea is to meet the pawn push with
a counter push so it's already a very
tricky decision for black to make how'd
you deal with it and he has done a very
understandable move there as well yeah
just got his Queen out the way in okay
Magnus after misplacing The Black Queen
now he insists on a bishop exchange this
bishop exchange is pretty much
guaranteed because uh if the black
Bishop runs away from this exchange then
The Rook falls behind it oh here we go
I'm gonna try and dig a hole now that's
why David should not be Frodo because
David is a pleasure to be here next to
you who would you say who who would you
like to beat David doing that because if
Magnus wins this game the tournament is
over the bar is definitely over to his
side and he has definitely more time on
the clock than Arjun as well he traded
off the dark squared Bishops I'm
surprised he did it on White's terms
look at that White Queen yeah so close
to the black king feels like trouble I
mean you could move the Knight back
around yeah I mean it just stops the
queen coming over to the defense of her
King okay he doesn't go for it Magnus uh
he plays one of the computer's top
choices we see that that was the third
choice by stockfish using the white Rook
also looks very good to be honest so for
example okay he does push forward wow
for example if the record locked we
would have seen an exchange and as Simon
mentioned this Pawn just drops white
would take it defended by the bishop you
know that 93 move end game that he
played with Vincent kaimer apparently
that a very very similar almost
identical position had happened what was
the best plan
and Magnus basically did that plan wow
Dublin so yeah I have to give credit
where it's due
it's a question for our guys who how to
improve his pieces and there he
centralizes his Queen
maybe okay there we go yeah and maybe
then the the pawn is ready to push so
black has to keep the Frets going Magda
slowing down okay he's gone for a little
bit
safer option but that night's also in
quite a good route and the pawn is still
ready to come forward
except from the one against Neiman yep
yep incredible
yeah and uh okay we'd like this move
right Simon we always like this move is
great Iris uh sorry uh the black porn
pushing
you're having to cause some kind of
confusion but probably if you don't have
much backup with any other piece except
for your queen and the black queen is
sort of I mean you're right you've got
to be positive Magnus does play this
move the most natural with the queen is
forced somewhere does she go this way
where she's not really doing too much
does she step back this way
where's the queen going okay so the good
a square as any I feel this one
um and there's a lot of tempting ideas
here do you improve your pieces here
again
um or do you try to push in the center
very quickly or maybe that Rook move
that you said David has so many moves
isn't there I think he's just improving
his pieces here
at some point later that will transform
into a direct attack quite likely
against the black king it looks like
it's hanging together by a thread for
black okay keep playing it so he's very
confident that the tactics are working
in his favor so if it works this could
be the end due to a pin and the black
Rook would fall he's gone all the way
back he's gone all the way back
immediately do you know what you should
have done David I think I think you said
it just resign yeah no I mean it's it's
that point of the game now three minutes
on the clock an extra two pawns on the
board potentially okay he drops back
with this Rook also understandable
hitting this Pawn now again every guys
he has to capture in the center
otherwise he's just gonna be two pawns
down for free and this is another idea
Simon you mentioned very typical very
thematic in this type of scenario uh so
let's just show on the board this would
be a check Pawn takes and it's gonna we
might see it David we are seeing this
threat on the board at least this would
end in Checkmate uh the bishop hits the
king the queen cuts off the King on this
diagonal
um I don't know it'd be I thought it's
bowden's mate with the two Bishops it is
balestra checkmates balestra oh yes
that's right don't get excited this is
what one thing that is very easy to get
carried away get excited this is also
very strong I think you can get ready to
push the pawn forwards but I mean it's
been so consistent throughout the
tournament you know the record-breaking
34 points in the preliminaries losing
just one game to Iranian undefended
maybe black can defend better there I'm
not sure okay Magnus we're gonna find
out he has opened up his Bishop
this bishop is a real Archer for Arjun
aragaisy do you think that means also
one minute left in uh the final
basically take this Pawn or do you want
to look across here maybe we're gonna
see this we're going to see it okay he's
given a check
and does the queen come over one square
it does yeah lining up against this
Knight only I only move to save of the
game is to use the Rook to defend yeah
is there something easier than that okay
he's going for this let's go for this
okay we see that position on the board
Queen takes Pawn has happened so white
will jump in with his Knight and still
looking good the black King's stuck in
the corner but uh
okay Eric I see but strategically still
dominant for white
and okay defensive piece has come along
you love those fiend Shadows definitely
I mean he's so good we know him for
attacking for being great in the opening
for being really smooth uh technically
in the end game but defensively he's
showing that
you know he's up there with the best
what is that what is the reason Magnus
is so much better in this game actually
everything looks you know and I look at
it it doesn't look like it to me King's
safety is the main thing if you take a
look at Black's King it's defended by
pieces and that's not the optimal use of
your pieces I mean you'd rather have the
Rope stopping track attacking yeah on
the center line
um so here white setup is he has the
kind of bodyguards in front of his King
the White Queen the white Rook White
Knight they're open to do what they want
the best fighters I'm still surprised as
well that the evaluation buys that much
in Black's favorite in magnus's favor
sorry but uh it's clearly clearly good
for white here five seconds oh I have to
make a move okay and he does thank you
Simon well I think you can just take the
rook and take the pawn next move Black's
Queen is coming out or black screen is
going to hit on the other well at least
I'm finding ways to lose this position
so this is a counter attack Black's
Queen is suddenly opened up a threat
against White's Rook on the side of the
board
I mean taking that black Rooks looks
like a good step I mean the white Rook
can always go up and take a pawn after
and you've got a queen
come to the background there are plenty
of ways but too much Rook can go and
take the Black Knights there's other
options yeah and uh he does take the
rook and now aragaisi has to catch the
rook and uh yeah Rook takes pawn and
Black's position is now starting to fall
apart yeah and uh now we do a quick
count white is also one point up with uh
an ongoing attack and Regice is trying
his best though the White Queen Under
threat but uh only for one move because
Magnus is the one that delivers a check
first and either black is gonna trade
off Rooks or he has to step forward with
his King and uh well rook's set of Rooks
are going to leave the board
yeah and now Magnus is going to start
mopping up he gives a queen track a
second potentially third Pawn is going
to fall
um I I still think I Regice is defended
so well but the problem is you're
playing the best player in the world and
you don't always have to go for
checkmate as Magnus is showing he's just
playing materially now he's going to
give another track most likely with the
White Queen
and the one thing he has to avoid Magnus
is the black queen coming in to start
checking the white king white King's
slightly vulnerable so with this check
Magnus loves to centralize his Queen
first of all but with this check he's
covering any potential Queen jumps uh
night jumps for black
and a big double threat hitting the
black queen and threatening to go with
the White Queen in front of black king
Checkmate and black has no checks him
and he has a knight check but it's it
doesn't help uh it's you can't stop chat
mate or losing your queen here yep
Checkmate is coming one way or the other
at the evaluation bar is shot all the
way up
no defense 10 seconds on the clock
he throws in one last desperate check
this Knight can just safely be captured
and maybe another check with the black
queen but I can't even block with the
queen here yeah simple way there we go
Magnus swapping the Queens off extra
Knight extra Pawn
he's gonna win the tournament wow and
there it is it's over ordinary guys he
resigns facing
possible world number one Magnus Carlsen
with a slight smile there